we've been given these two integrals and
you can see in the way that i've written
them
they are intended to be related and
hopefully this is potentially ringing
some bells
from what we had to look at on tuesday's
lessons if you have your
notes still there and you like flick
back you're like huh this is different
but reminds me of what we did then and
hopefully i can point out why
let's uh before we get into that have a
look at question one which anger has
helpfully
provided us working for right here you
can see he's chosen his
you dv this is the way he set it out so
he's going from
use this color from his u to his d u
here and he's dv on dx2 here's v here
are you happy with his choice of u and
dv
looks pretty good to me as well you know
when you think about the dv here we
pulled out this trick
of saying when something doesn't look
like a product we can still express it
as a product
by considering one as part of the
product so
things look good you get this hunky-dory
right i should point out i mean this is
not too bad but
every time i do integration by parts
every single time
the answer comes out and it's so like
out of thin air
i cannot help but always just give it
another like differentiate to see
if it comes back right i don't know if
you've looked at some of the integrals
that you end up with you're like
okay i guess like i got it out of a
fairly straightforward process but
who would have guessed at this right
like there is this and you'll see by the
way if you try and differentiate it
you'll get all of the terms so nicely
cancelling out you're like oh
oh yes it does work okay what a relief
are you happy with that
yeah help me out as we have a go at two
together when you start to whirl through
this question
what is your choice of u and dv
it should ring a whole lot of bells yeah
go ahead uh
you having your l and squared
is leaving
yep like so okay um you look at this and
you say
i again i don't have any like i could
make them log x
and log x but then i'm gonna have to
integrate like if i choose this to be
log x i'm going to have to integrate
that and we you know if you think about
detail right it's l is right at the
bottom so we're trying to avoid that as
much as we can
so it seems weird that even though we're
building off of this we're going to
pull the same trick but it does work
because what do you do we get out of
this
we get 2
yep power comes out the front power
reduces by one
time and then you multiply by
the inside derivative yeah which is one
over x in this case
and then our v just like we saw before
you get x
raise the string of l so then when we go
ahead
and write our
integral we're going to get u v here we
go
x log x squared minus help me out
say it with me integral of
2 log x because these x's will cancel
okay with that
2 log x dx is that all right
now what we've done again i'm trying to
ring this bell from tuesday right what
we've done is we've gone from
integration by parts
and then created something which
requires another application
of integration by parts which is why
there's this hints here thankfully we've
already worked out what that particular
integral is we've just got minus two of
them
do you agree is that right so therefore
what i've got over here
x log x or squared and then minus two
lots of
and then i'm just gonna put all of that
in does that make sense
x log x take away x and then here comes
my constant
are you satisfied with that does that
look okay now what you've done here
right hopefully you've started to
realize
like i mean i could keep on climbing up
this ladder forever if i wanted right
i could do i suppose in theory log
x or cubed because if you went and
rehearsed this process
you would still choose dv to be one
because you'll do anything you can to
avoid a log appearing here
you'll put log x or cubed up the top
and if you did that think about this
would be maybe you want to drop this
part down
if we put in u equals log x or cubed
what will our
d u become
what are we gonna get three
yep three ln x all squared there's the
outside derivative and then we divide by
x there's the times one over x
inside derivative right now that's going
to appear in our v
d u the x's again will cancel but then
what you'll get in this
next integral the integral of v to u is
like oh this looks familiar
it's this thing right well actually it's
minus three of them but you get the idea
okay so this whole idea here should
hopefully ring bells
from not just tuesday's lesson of an
integration by parts process
that required another integration by
parts but i want you to think even
further back
i want you to think back to proof proof
you might recall
had two components to it there was the
nature of proof where we introduced all
that weird
contrapositive by contradiction language
all that kind of thing do you remember
what the second part was
it should it was a continuation of
something directly from extension one
it was further induction right we looked
at induction and like harder versions of
it
we looked at induction where you had
something
that kind of referred back to an earlier
version of itself
i don't expect you to remember this
phrase but we call them first order
recurrence formulas do you remember
those first order recurrence formulas
it's like ah
something that returns back or refers
back to itself
now these things here are kind of
recurrence
integrals right it's an integral that
refers back to like an earlier version
of itself we call these here comes the
heading
recurrence relations
though you will see
some texts or some websites have a
slightly different name
but hopefully you'll see why it's called
that they will sometimes call these
reduction formulas or formulae
because the whole idea is this process
of integration produces another integral
but it's like
slightly lesser right you see that if we
went up to the next step and did log x
or cubed
you'd create this one which is slightly
lesser it's like a reduced version
of that okay so what we want to do is we
want to try and generalize this process
i'd really rather not have to go
like one two three four etc if i
possibly can
so now what i'd like you to do you can
even call this question three
if you like i want you to consider what
if we
had log x raised to
some arbitrary power n
what would happen out of this now before
you go any further
excuse me let me introduce or extend
some notation we've used before
that will help us tackle this particular
question right
you see how we've got these uh versions
of the interview which are getting more
and more complicated right
we customarily call our integrals
capital i
right it's like call this thing capital
i that's what we did on tuesday so it
could refer back to itself
but here we've got like increasingly
complicated versions of capital i
so what we're going to do to make it
easy for us to keep track of things is
if you call this thing here i won like
the first version of it
right the next one is just well the next
version so i'm going to call it i
2. you can imagine if i went up to this
what would we call this
i3 right and so on and so on so here
at say this line right here
right we could say oh look i've gotten
this part out
uv and then what i've created is minus
two lots of
i two does that make sense
so what i can do is i can use this
language i would call this
i look at the power n right it's the nth
one
okay you'll even see some textbooks call
this rather than i for integral
they'll call it t capital t like just
like a
term in an arithmetic or geometric
progression right
because you're building on top of
whatever came before
what are you going to get help me out
here like we've done this
twice two and a half times what is going
to happen out of this can you do you
have enough to follow a pattern
have a think look what happened the
first time
here this is our first line now u v
minus v d u
here's what happened the second time
here's our u v
minus v d u make a guess
making conjecture what do you think the
uv is going to look like
yeah oh yeah
oh yeah no you're absolutely right yeah
i always think of the next one
thank you trin
let's see if we can identify some sort
of pattern between
i need this color this will do here's
the uv that we got the second time
here's the uv that we got the first time
what do you see that's consistent
well the x is there because we keep on
we keep on consistently choosing
uh dv is one right and so you get your v
as
x so i'm gonna go ahead and put that
down what changes from
i one up to i two yeah
the log x term right this comes from u
up here
so as you climb up this time i've
climbed up all the way up to the nth
step of the ladder so therefore i'm
going to get log x
to the n is that okay this next bit you
have to think a little more carefully
maybe have think about this clue that i
gave you up here if we went up to the
third step
right here we had how many lots of this
we had one of them
here i had two of them
how many am i going to have here there's
three
so if i went all the way to the nth one
how many am i likely to have
n of them right because you're going to
have u being equal to log x to the power
of
n you differentiate and you get n
log x to the let's actually do this part
right minus
integral of n outside of
log x to the n minus 1
right here's the n minus 1 here it's 1
minus 1 it's zero that's why there are
no log x terms there
here's the 1 log x term here i've got 2
right there there's the n minus 1. so
here's an n minus 1
like so is that all right
now you can see if i call this
this thing here if i call this i
n then what is this
yeah that n is just a constant
coefficient right there's no n
in here so i'll pop that in out the
front and then
everything that's left is oh look it's a
log x to a different power
so that'd be the previous term you can
see why these are called
recurrence relations it's exactly the
same thing that those recursive formulas
look like
back when we're doing induction make
sense
now if i then therefore off of the basis
of this in fact i'll even write that
on the next line i and equals
here's our x log x term minus
there we go this is the definition of
any kind of recursive formula it refers
back to an older version
of itself if i then ask you to go say
and work out what's i5
right you could just go ahead and put
that in you'd have to climb back down
the ladder until some point where you
knew what the integral was right
because if i put in i5 here you'll just
get an i4 here you're like i don't know
what i4 is so then you'd have to work
out what i4 is
and so on you get a string of terms okay
but you could work this out
none the less